[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue sur France 24 et
sur Radio France Internationale notre
invité aujourd'hui et le président du
Burundi est varice daichimié avec moi
pour cette interview Laurent Koro de RFI
monsieur le Président bonjour bonjour
monsieur le Président vous exercez
actuellement la présidence tournante de
la Communauté des États d'Afrique de
l'Est leac et vous avez notamment pour
but de tenter d'apaiser les tensions
entre le Rwanda et la RDC on voit que la
situation reste très tendue sur le
terrain alors est-ce que vous pensez que
les conditions du négociation sont
réunies à l'heure actuelle
d'abord c'est la question de dialogue de
réconciliation entre les États leur
rapprochement c'est d'abord un pas
accepter de s'asseoir ensemble c'est un
pas donc moi je considère que il
beaucoup de rencontres et aussi j'ai vu
que la communauté internationale aussi
et
très conscient de son processus donc que
ça soit les Nations Unies aussi une
Européenne le président Macron en tant
que président du Conseil de l'Union
européenne lui aussi
il a mis
sa main pour que l'on puisse retrouver
la paix dans cette région mais est-ce
que le gouvernement congolais accuse à
raison le gouvernement rwandais de
soutenir le M23 bon jusqu'à maintenant
on n'a pas encore tracé au niveau de la
région que ce soit moi-même mais comme
nous prévoyons une réunion de
consultation avec le facilitateur dans
son conflit le président angolais on
aura quand même l'occasion d'analyser et
voir la réalité des choses
alors vous participez le Burundi
participe également à la force
d'interposition régionale de la
Communauté des États d'Afrique de l'Est
qui a été envoyé en RDC alors est-ce que
vous allez envoyer plus de troupes mais
aussi est-ce que vous ne craignez pas
quand
vous lancez armez en vous battant contre
des groupes armés les violences
ne déborde chez vous dans votre pays
d'abord ne participez pas
régional le Burundi a
des bataillons on n'a pas encore envoyé
tout un troupes et pour le moment mais
on a envoyé plus d'un bataillon et nous
agissons dans le cadre régional c'est
pas dans le cadre de l'État burundé et
puis
je pense que ça ne va pas embraser le
conflit parce que de 1 les burundai et
les Congolais sont comme des frères il
n'y a pas de temps sur entre le peuple
congolais et le peuple burundai et ils
ont confiance à notre armée l'armée
borontaine le sud qui vaut c'est d'abord
il y a l'état-major général de la force
régionale qui a déployé les forces et
chaque pays a son secteur d'action le
Burundi va s'occuper de la raison du sud
de qui vous et depuis que notre force
est là vous voyez que il y a la
stabilité
et les groupes armés qui ont opéré aussi
de qui vous ont eu confiance de la
sécurité des forces burundaises qui
opèrent avec les forces
armées de la RDC et les communautés
locales ont eu confiance de sécurité
jusqu'à ce que même les groupes armés
acceptent de déposer les armes parce
qu'ils avaient confiance en cette force
régionale il y a un peu moins de 2 mois
monsieur le Président la frontière
terrestre avec le Rwanda était rouverte
au transit est-ce que vous diriez que
les relations sont désormais apaisées
avec votre voisin rwandais jusqu'à
maintenant il n'y a pas de trace entre
le Burundi et le Rwanda s'il y a des
questions qui restent encore à être
réglées ce sont des questions qui sont
règles diplomatiquesment nous sommes
toujours en contact nos officiers
parlent avec les officiers rwandais et
les administratifs au niveau des
frontières les gouverneurs de provinces
sont rencontrées souvent même ça fait
presque une semaine et demie pour
administration de la province de kirondo
a rencontré l'administration de la
province de Bougui sera donc il y a une
embellie donc finalement
les questions qui restent à régler ce
sont des questions qui sont réglées et
progressivement mais cela n'empêche pas
que l'épée qu'on continue à son visite
loin d'être
sa liberté sur le lac est tanganical et
burunday aussi vont visiter les les amis
qui sont donc je peux dire que il n'y a
pas de casseurs et il est en train de
dépays est-ce que ça veut dire que vous
avez renoncé à votre demande qui était
une condition que le Rwanda extrade les
opposants burunday accusés d'avoir
fomenté le coup d'État de 2015 c'était
une condition que vous avez posé vous
avez donc renoncé vous vous avez vu que
il y a eu beaucoup de rencontres
j'ai envoyé des émissaires Rwanda qui
ont rencontré le président Kagame aussi
le président
qui sont venus me voir tout cela dans le
cadre de discussion il y a eu rencontré
entre les juristes les délégués du
ministère de la Justice qui ont
rencontré les délégués du ministère de
la justice rwandaise et donc et ça sera
rencontré des techniciens continuent à
discuter sur les modalités pratiques ce
qui est important et que Rwanda
reconnaît que ces petites se trouvent et
c'est lui et que le Burundi aussi
parce que Rwanda vend va les remettre et
pour aller devant la justice burundaise
et ce qui est très important maintenant
nous sommes presque c'est comme si nous
sommes bloqués parce que nous ne pouvons
pas gérer ceux qui ont sont déjà jugés
et les autres qui restent alors que la
tête reste toujours
sans être jugé alors très difficile de
gérer cette question c'est pour cela que
nous demandons toujours au Rwanda de
remettre ces petites pour qu'il soit
jugés avec les autres et comme ça trop
le groupe sera alors gérer politiquement
quand la justice aura fait son travail
et donc ce que vous nous dites c'est que
c'est en bonne voie vous vous avez bon
espoir que ces gens-là vont être
extradés bientôt par le Rwanda nous
avons l'espoir parce que nous voyons
qu'il y a quand même la volonté quand
ils acceptaient de d'abord de mettre
cette question sur la table et tout le
monde de cet enfant d'or que ça soit du
Rwanda
que nous allons la gérer ensemble vous
appelez la communauté internationale à
venir vous aider à investir mais par
exemple les budgétaire de l'Union
européenne n'a toujours pas été débloqué
il y a toujours des désaccords sur la
feuille de route pourquoi est-ce que
vous espérez bientôt un accord sur ce je
crois qu'il n'y a pas de désaccord
plutôt nous sommes dans le dialogue
pour voir en dans quel domaine ils
peuvent appuyer donc on y aura-t-il cet
accord avec l'Union européenne
vous ne savez pas qu'à la réunion va se
terminer mais ce qui est intéressant
c'est que
tout le monde est attiré et nous parlons
presque le même langage nous allons
ensemble et nous allons réussir ensemble
lors de ces dernières réunion monsieur
le Président le Conseil des droits de
l'homme de l'ONU a adopté une résolution
dans laquelle il condamne ce qu'il
appelle l'impunité généralisée pour
toutes les violations des droits de
l'homme dans votre pays ils demandent à
votre gouvernement de faire en sorte que
tous les acteurs de telle violation
qu'ils soient membres des forces de
défense et de sécurité ou membres du
mouvement de jeunesse du parti les îles
bonnets rassurées est à répondre de
leurs actes est-ce que c'est une demande
à laquelle vous êtes prêtes à répondre
en tant que chef de l'État
c'est en parler de cette jeunesse
aujourd'hui tous les jeunes tous les
jeunes du pays sont mobilisés vers le
développement vous savez que j'organise
des retraites de jeunes intellectuels
j'organise au moins deux fois par
semaine mais vous comptez le président
l'ampleur des violations des droits de
l'homme dénoncé par cette commission non
vraiment jusque maintenant on en a pas
encore montré là où il y a une violation
des droits de l'homme je sais que il n'y
a pas une personne qui commet un crime
et qui reste infini vraiment là je me
mets moi-même vous savez j'ai mis à la
disposition de tous les citoyens mon
numéro de téléphone mon numéro WhatsApp
c'est de chaque fois crier violation des
droits de l'homme partout toujours de
noces et je dois assurer le suivi donc
là je peux vous garantir au moins chaque
jour
s'il y a quelque chose qui se passe même
s'il y a un justice la population de
noces alors comment ça peut être qu'il y
a quelques qui est à l'extérieur qui
voit les choses que la population
elle-même d'abord les victimes
maintenant ont le droit de dénoncer
c'est le président de la République
alors qu'est-ce que c'est lui qui a à
l'extérieur peut connaître que moi je ne
connais pas je pense que ce sont des
détracteurs qui font la contre
propagande c'est normal est-ce que vous
êtes près du coup à accueillir
l'observateur de la Commission des
droits de l'homme de l'ONU pour qu'il
puisse constater de lui-même tout cela
au Burundi et je ne sais pas si vous
avez écouté mon discours à l'Assemblée
générale des Nations Unies
à cause de ces gens-là qui veulent faire
des rapports biaisés j'ai demandé aux
commissariat des droits de l'homme et
des Nations Unies de venir au Burundi
pour nous asseoir ensemble analysant
ensemble la situation et voir ensemble
ce que nous pouvons faire pour améliorer
améliorer davantage la protection des
droits de l'homme donc n'avons pas peur
que la le recommencer
et discuter c'est comment gérer ensemble
des questions des droits de l'homme dans
mon pays dernière question le Conseil
des droits de l'homme de l'ONU encore
lui appellent votre gouvernement à nouer
un véritable dialogue sans exclusive
avec tous les parties burunday que ce
soit à l'extérieur et à l'intérieur
évidemment il y a certains partis qui
sont toujours interdits pour vous c'est
une ligne rouge vous refusez d'ouvrir un
dialogue avec ses groupes-là
par exemple la justice pas
tu ne peux pas tuer quelqu'un et dire je
vais négocier avec le gouvernement c'est
ça l'impunité parce qu'il y a des
victimes qui réclament les justices
alors
qui protégeait entre la victime et donc
tu ne peux pas dire en matière pénale
que tu vas réconcilier les
matières si vous avez commis un crime
c'est la justice qui doit faire son
travail mais aussi mais aussi quand la
justice se termine son travail il y a
cette fois sur la gestion la gestion des
condamnés il y a des mécanismes
mesdamesnistie de mécanismes de gras de
mes aides il y a tout mais avant tout il
faut privilégier la justice après le
travail de la justice c'est là où il y a
un autre travail donc maintenant ceux
qui sont ceux qui ont commis des crimes
doivent répondre parce que les victimes
réclament toujours justice imagenez-vous
si aujourd'hui on laissait les gens qui
ont commis des crimes et quelle victime
est sauvages
qui sera responsable de tout cela c'est
le gouvernement qui sera responsable
parce que il n'a pas protégé les
victimes donc je pense que la justice
doit être privé privilégié avant tout
merci monsieur le Président merci
d'avoir répondu à nos questions et merci
à vous tous de nous avoir suivis sur nos
deux chaînes rfiées France 24
[Musique]